[Mark] Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier,
and this is Tyler. Say hi.
[Tyler] Hi.
[Mark] If you're wondering why we're wearing gloves,
or wondering why there's a block of dry ice right in front of us,
we're about to do a chay-llenge.
[Tyler] Chaaayyyllleennggee?
[Mark] Shut the fuck up.
[both laughing]
[Mark] So, we're going to be doing the "Dry Ice Popsicle Challenge."
and if you don't know what that is... I need my phone.
So here's how this is gonna work:
we've got an assortment of both good and bad tasting things
that we're going to turn into popsicles on this dry ice.
[SFX: Yelp of discomfort]
We've made a little indentation here,
and then I'm going to enjoy a nice, REGULAR popsicle,
and get a popsicle stick out of it before we have to do this horrible challenge,
where we have an assortment of... Terrifying and horrible and disgusting elements.
We've got vegan mayonnaise - tartar sauce.
Chipotle garlic sauce.
Honey mustard yogurt dressing.
We got Mountain Dew, we got Coke.
Gatorade protein shake.
Off-brand Sriracha-
organic!
Kale parmesan... Vinaigrette.
Which I don't even know if it's gonna freeze or not.
We have root beer, blueberry smoothie- we have carrot smoothie. We have pure chocolate sauce.
Lemon and lime, and we're gonna mix into a zesty popsicle.
So, what gonna happen is - Tyler and I, we're gonna have a little competition;
something you may know about: we're gonna play rock paper scissors
for our soul.
Mmm- Rock Paper Scissors Shoot!
The loser has to generate a random number: one through thirteen.
And that is this (*referring to the tartar sauce*) being 1, these (*referring to the lemon/lime juice*) being 13.
Going down the line. Here are some magical numbers popping up!
[Mark making boop sounds]
Then we'll pour this in this, and then we will eat that-
with- but, first I'm gonna enjoy this.
You wanna bite of this actual good popsicle before we have to ruin our tastebuds?
[Tyler] I- I like this idea.
[Sensual music]
Okay, we've had one bite, that's good enough for us- bwep!
Okay, we've got our popsicle stick, which is the only popsicle stick we got because *somebody* forgot to get them at the store.
[u w0t m8? wanna fite?]
[Tyler] He's a liar.
[Mark] He forgot!
It's time...Oh.
[Tyler laughs]
[Mark] Don't know why I have both of these on...It's really-
I'm- I'm totally about that protection!
Alright...
Rock paper scissors shoot!
[Tyler] Dammit!
[Mark] Yes!
[Mark] Yes! Okay, so you have to generate a random number
[Mark] I don't think-
[Tyler] It's not...
[Mark] Oh! Thirteen! You get lemon-
[Tyler] Oooh! Yes, save!
[Mark] So he got lemon & lime, so it's pure lime juice and pure lemon juice, so it can't be that bad.
It's not popping...
[Tyer] Mine popped!
[Mark] Oh- mine popped. Mine popped before yours!
[Tyler] LIAR!
[SFX: whoosh sound]
[Mark] Eugh...
[Tyler] No, you just squeeze.
[Mark] Okay, fine then.
Okay, that's good enough
I like how I have the glove for safety,
and I'm squirting with my non-gloved hand.
[Tyler laughs]
Oh! I can kinda see it freezing around the edges here.
Ooh look, it's freezing!
Zoom in on that!
[SFX: Ominous spooky ambience accompanied by a woman's scream]
Yeeaahh that's the stuff
Yiiah! Okay, bring me the water.
We're just gonna- every time we get through one, we're gonna put it down below,
Uhh, just so it's out of the way.
[Tyler] Yeh, yeh.
[Mark] Okay...
[Tyler] We gotta dip- woah!
[Mark] Here, you! You do it.
[Tyler] We gotta dip it in the water or else we eat CO2. [Laughs]
[Mark] Yeah, we don't want that.
[Tyler] Alright!
[Mark] Go for it.
[Mark] Oh that's a boober on the end of that thing!
[Laughs]
[Mark laughing]
[Tyler] *incomprehensible* -aww, it's sour!
[Mark continues to laugh]
[Tyler] It's really sour!
[Mark] It had a big droopy boober! Let me try this.
[Tyler] It's really tart, and sour.
[Mark] It's not so bad...
*Gently grunts*
-okay! It get's worse!
[Tyler laughing]
[Tyler] I like sour, so it's not all that bad!
[Mark] Yeah, I like that!
[Mark] It's not sweet, if you put some sugar in there you'd have a lemonade-
Your eyes are like, so red!
[Both laughing]
[Mark] We got a Ziploc bag down here;
we're gonna put all the liquids in here, and then freeze that at the end of it.
[Tyler] So, all of them mixed together and we both have to take a bite of it...
[Mark] Yes! Stop procrastinating, and let's get to this.
[Mark] *grunts*
[Tyler] Yyyes!!
[Tyler] Yes!
[Mark] Y- you know what? It could be good..
[Mark] It could be good!
[Mark] Two!
[Tyler laughing in celebration]
[Mark] I mean- it's not that bad!
[Tyler] It's something that's not necessarily super liquidy...
[Mark] I dunno, could be not bad.
[Mark] Actually, it doesn't smell so bad!
[Tyler] Let me take a whiff..
[Mark] It doesn't smell so bad.
[Tyler] That smells pretty good!
[Mark] Okay, alright.
[Tyler] That smells pretty good; I'd like that on my wings-
oh, do we gotta put the popsicle stick on here?
[Mark] Yeah, I'm gonna put just a little bit.
*CAMERA STOPPED*
[Sarcastically cheery music playing]
[Mark] It's recording again!
[Tyler humming]
[Mark] Sorry!
[Mark] It's pretty solid, it's gettin' solid!
[Tyler] Oh it's pretty solid. Pretty solid.
[Mark] It's getting solid! Okay.
[Tyler] It's just taking a while.
[Mark] Alright.
[Mark & Tyler making moans of caution]
Oh- oof ... Eugh.
[Mark] This is awful.
[Tyler] Eww, it's slimey!
[Mark] No- give it to me! Let me do it!
[Mark] A little bit of sludge, but that's okay.
Oh, and a hair! Aww that's lovely! I'm glad that's there.
[Mark] Alright: ready?
[smacking of lips as Mark makes faces at his creation]
[Tyler laughing] I'm not biting that one!
[Mark] It's- ...
It's not... bad?
But it tastes wrong? [laughing]
Well, that one was bad.
[Yawning] When are we gonna get a good one?
[Tyler] YES again!
[Laughing & celebrating]
[Mark] Jeez, you are too happy about my misery.
Okay, so uhm - I'm gonna drop it down to- uh, ... Eleven.
So now, that's one, two three...
[Tyler also counting]
[Mark] Okay, ready?
[Tyler] Yup.
[Mark makes a soft *blink* sound with his mouth]
[Mark] Aww!!
[Tyler laughing]
[Mark & Tyler laughing]
[Mark] Oh, come on!
[Tyler does a weird tribunal chant]
[Mark] What if it's good?
[Mark] What if it's good - I like tartar sauce.
It definitely smells more like mayonnaise, but-
Its- it's not bad! Maybe, I don't know! [laughs]
Oh, this doesn't pour! [laughing]
[Tyler] Here-
[Mark] this doesn't poor! Alright, I got it.
Just a- just a, uh - a few dollops!
Just a few dollop- oh, that's chunky!
[Tyler laughs]
[Mark] Oh that's nice n' chunky!
[Tyler] Alright.
[Mark] I'm gonna get a mini popsicle going on here, because-
[Tyler] It's like a lollipop!
[Mark] Oh- oh- oh nooo!
[Mark] Oh no... Oh nooo..
[Tyler laughing]
[Both] Oooooohh!
[Both laughing]
[Mark] Ooh-ho-ho that is so gross!
[Tyler laughing] I win!
[Mark] Aw, that's so gross!
I'm gonna... I'm gonna flip this so the other side gets a little toast.
Y'know, you want an even toast on your...
[Mark] Feel like the way that looks.
[Tyler laughing]
[Mark] Oh jeez
Okay...
[Mark] It's... It's still sludgy.
[Tyler laughing]
Aagghh
It's still sludgy.
[Tyler laughing]
[Mark] Okay, now it's warming up. It just tastes like tartar sauce.
[Mark laughing] But at first, man my mouth was sending me all the wrong signals about what that was.
Doone.
[Tyler] I feel like you're backwards.
[Mark incredulously] What? How am I backwards?
[Tyler] Cuz I have a gloved hand on top...
[Mark] Ooohh, that would... but I can't play rock paper scissors with my left hand.
[Both laughing]
I'd be at a disadvantage
[Tyler] I'm pretty sure you won the last time you did it with your left hand.
[Mark] No I didn't!
[Tyler] The first one you did.
[Mark] I never did it with my left hand.
[Tyler] Didn't you do...
Roll back the tape.
[Mark] See? I didn't.
[Both laughing]
[Tyler] He totally did!
[Mark] Rock, paper, scissors, shoot!
Rock, paper, scissors, shoot!
[Mark] Yeeaahhh!
[Tyler] Noooo!
[Mark] Yes!
[Tyler] Where's the generator?
[Mark] Okay, we're dropping it down to ten now.
So that's one... yeah, same thing.
[Mark] Alright, there we go, ten.
[Tyler] Ten
[Mark] Oh, the chocolate.
[Tyler] 7, 8, 9...
[Tyler] Oh yeah!
[Mark] That's so stupid.
[Tyler] Yeeaahh!
[Mark] That looks delicious.
That looks incredible.
That looks delicious!
That looks fantastic!
Make a bigger popsicle, I want some of that.
Make it bigger!
Oh god it's droopin', don't wash it that much.
[Mark] Oh god, get it in your mouth.
[Tyler laughing]
[Mark] Aaagghh
Doesn't taste as good as I thought it'd be.
It's chocolaty.
[Tyler] It's chocolaty.
[Mark] Mmmmm
[Tyler] I think it's that off brand.
[Mark] Yeah.
It's not Hershey's brand.
[Tyler] This was not sponsored by Hershey's.
[Mark] This is not sponsored by any of these shit...
[Tyler] Woahh.
[Mark] You okay there? Got a little droop?
Alright, let's do this again. C'mon.
[Mark] Yeeaahh!
[Tyler] Noooo!
[Mark] Get a bad one, you sack of crap.
[Both] Five
[Mark] Yeeaahh!
[Tyler] Noooo!
[Mark] The one you didn't want.
[Mark] It's sriracha!
Yeah, and it's off brand sriracha too.
[Mark] Yeah-ha-ha
[Tyler] If I die it's Mark's fault.
[Mark] Here, squirt away.
Squirt it all in there
Splat it all around.
You're just going to do a tiny dob? No! Get more than that.
You gotta cover the, cover the stick at least.
We're doing the tiniest popsicles ever apparently, when you have to eat something gross.
[Tyler] Freeze, freeze, freeze sriracha
[Mark] Shut the fuck up.
[Mark] Eat, eat, eat sriracha. Eat sriracha now.
You are not gonna like it, [in Scottish accent] you're not gonna like it now.
Don't know why I'm Scottish, don't, don't mind me.
Ohh, this is lovely.
[Tyler] It looks like a tongue.
[Mark] Good!
[Tyler] Ehh...
[Mark] It probably tastes like a tongue.
[Mark] That's a good popsicle.
Now that's a popsicle right there. [Laughing] There, that's the stuff.
That's the good stuff. That's the good stuff.
[Mark] Well, how's the taste? How's the texture?
[Tyler] I don't like sriracha.
[Tyler] It's very gooey once it starts melting.
[Mark] Nice!
[Tyler] Take a small bite.
[Mark] No.
[Tyler] Yes.
[Mark] This is not part of the deal.
[Tyler] This is part of the deal, we've all done it. I had...
[Mark] I didn't... I didn't... I didn't...
[Mark] We, we all. The two of us.
[Tyler] We all did it.
[Mark] Everyone here did it.
[Tyler] Just, just a tiny bit.
[Tyler] Just a tiny, tiny bit.
Gughh
Aggghh
Oh it's so bad. Oh it's so bad.
Eughh-hu-hu
It's so bad. Why did I have to do that?
I didn't have to do that.
That's not part of the challenge.
Then there's no point in being happy when you get bad ones.
If I get a good one, you're not having any of it.
[Tyler] You had the chocolate!
[Mark] Shut up. It wasn't that good.
Ready? Rock, paper, scissors, shoot.
[Tyler] Dammit!
[Mark] Yes!
[Both] Four
[Mark] Protein shake!
Yeaahh!
[Tyler] I don't know if this is working real well...
[Tyler] Oh!
[Mark] Ah, dude.
[Mark] It's the, it's the C02.
[Tyler] Nooo
[Mark] You're not gonna win this fight man.
Bill Nye the Science Guy
[Both slowly] Bill Nye the Science Guy
Bill! Bill! Bill! Bill! Bill! Bill! Bill! Bill! Bill!
[Mark] Bill! Bill! Bill! Bill! Bill!
[Tyler] Bill Nye the Science Guy
Bill! Byill! Byaahlll!
[Tyler] Byaahlll!
[Mark] Byaahlll!
[Tyler] I thought you were going to hit me.
[Mark] Why would I hit you?
[Mark] Yeaahh, look at that.
Look at that man.
That's probably not that bad.
[Tyler] It's hard to pick up.
[Mark] Shut up.
[Tyler] Alright.
[Mark] Go for it.
[Tyler] Not bad.
[Mark] Yeah, it's probably not bad.
[Tyler] Tastes kind of like a vanilla ice cream pop.
[Mark] Oh, nice ... No
[Tyler] You sure?
Yeah, we're gonna, we need a little separation here because,
then there's no risk.
There's no risk reward if I keep eating it.
So no.
[Tyler] I told you it tastes like vanilla ice cream.
[Mark] That's not bad. I want some.
[Tyler] You told me you didn't want any!
[Tyler] I'm gonna win this time.
[Mark] Sure you are.
[Mark] Rock, paper, scissors, shoot.
Rock, paper, scissors, shoot.
[Tyler] Dammit!
[Mark] Yeeaahh!
[Mark] Ah-ha-ha-ha-ha-haahh Ha-ha-haaaah
[Tyler] What is that? Four in a row?
[Mark] Yeah, hell yeah man.
[Tyler] Shit.
[Mark] You suck at rock paper scissors dude.
[Both] Six.
[Mark] Ohh, ahhh, that's not too bad.
[Tyler] Berry ... Blue goodness!
[Mark] It's blueberry.
[Tyler] It's got blueberry and black...
[Mark] It's got blueberry.
[Tyler] Blackberry.
[Mark] It's got blackberry.
[Tyler] Blueberries!?
[Tyler] Blueberries, blackberries, banana, and apple.
[Mark] What the hell was that?
[Mark] Blueberries
I hypothesize that's it got blueberries in it.
Pour!
Get away from the stupid joke  that I made and pour.
[Tyler] It smells good.
[Mark] Oh yeah, oh that's gonna be delicious.
[Mark] It's gonna be wonderful.
[Tyler] It's gonna be really good.
[Tyler] So in order to conserve some time,
we're gonna do rock paper scissors for the next one, while this one is still freezing.
[Mark] Cuz we've got two channels here until this one disappears,
but we've got enough time for one more thing so we're gonna do this.
Don't lose.
[Mark] Rock, paper, scissors, shoot
[Intense Music]
[Narrator] Next time on the "Dry Ice Popsicle Challenge"
The boys reveal the bag of horrors waiting for them.
Who will be the one to partake?
Who will be the one to suffer?
And who will win the "Dry Ice Popsicle Challenge"?
Find out next time on Dragon Ball Z.